що зараз на вашому напрямку розкажи
наскільки гаряче ну війна - це зрозуміла
окупантів
вдається без якихось труднощі тому що
війна це за завжди треба завжди важко
але головне те що він знає що ми робимо
бо там захищаємо свою богам данну землю
а що робити російської команди ну дають
добривом для нашого і без того дуже
гарного дня
з приводу останніх подій з приводу от
вільнюського саміту НАТО і всього того
що після нього почалося одставлення
військових все-таки треба нам в НАТО чи
ні
розумієте тобто Велика політика
дипломатія це дуже-дуже велика Шахова
гра я скажу більше якщо Бо Україна свого
часу ні Vaillant цей шанс ми будемо нато
То нічого буде зараз не було ми зараз
тут не стояли я зараз був десь на
риболовлі сиднора теж займаються якимось
своїми справами але ми зробили помилку
тоді і дуже дуже важлива ці помилка мені
зробити вдруге Нам все одно треба йти в
НАТО Нам все одно треба Альянс ці клуб
обраних який гарантує безпеку будь-який
країні яка являється членом НАТО з
приводу останніх от таких дуже
розповсюджених фейсбучних страчів з
приводу і без приводу всі українці
чіпляться між собою от що би ти їм
сказав звідси з зі сходу
вторая поговорка називається разделяє
власності
вот взял её на озброєння а єдиний
українець які стоять єдиним фронтом і
ключом ключ дуже-дуже відповідно напруга
для Кремля це дуже потужна сила і Кремль
накладає шалених зусиль
14-15-го року щоби в нас поділити
роз'ємник і зараз вони це роблять і ти
вважаєш що ноги все-таки скремлять
і грають і грають в темну вони вважають
що вони роблять якусь та гарну справу
Але давайте згадаємо Ну я не буду
конечно Леон Андрія Макаревича
маріонетки вот танцы лешенька Ну і
підсумок що тоді з цим всім робити
розуміти що за наши помилки а потім
плати плати Україна платить тим чого не
можна десь взяти Це життя своїх громадян
як цивільних так і військових На жаль ми
знов підемо до тих грабель на які ми
знов наступимо і потім бігати будемо по
колу і співати сумні пісні сидіти на
футболіста річки трасу Ну буду
українською треба нам дорослі